nina you had the thrill of being one of
the biggest christmas movies of all time
uh love actually playing hugh grant's uh
it was private secretary
yeah yeah there he was
and that's evil isn't it annoyingly
untouched by time you grant looks like a
school boy
you look exactly the same that's just
because i haven't changed my hair
for 30 years or something yeah that's
his mistake but you didn't get
how big this film kind of remains no i
had no idea
maybe i just don't watch telly at
christmas but
um i had no idea it was showing every
year
because i don't get a check every year
yeah i would have reminded that helps
yeah
yeah but pretty many people come up to
you about it oh yeah and i've
realized recently i was uh filming
killing eve i think it was and there was
a a youngish man
i thought he was just sort of you know
my age but clearly not
um and we'd been filming for quite a
while and then we were sat sort of
somewhere something like this and he was
sort of
looking at me and going can i can i just
say uh
that it's just really weird sitting next
to you because you're
in my house every christmas and i've
grown up with you on
grown up
on screen on christmas day and even if
they didn't put the sound up it's on
it's just on i'm in his living room and
have been since he can
ever since he can remember which is
worrying really